so we're glad you could join me today
I'm Leonard mesh Boettcher the
psychotherapist to the superheroes they
call me renowned in any case take a look
at some of these sessions and you'll see
the kind of work that goes on here so
I'm sensing some some tension between
the two of you right now yes I'm right
she's been very passive aggressively
you got to be frank and direct can you
do that storm you know we can't we can't
read your mind well maybe maybe you
can't
storm are you controlling my humidifier
again I don't want you to do that storm
storm Thank You superheroes help other
people that's that's what they're in the
business to do but so often they've got
issues around Dada da Dada issues
Dada how did it feel is my question
Luke when you boundary with your father
he cut off my hand
I sure would like you to use those I
feel statements I feel bad I feel sad I
feel I feel like flipping you off right
now okay could have been more affected I
don't know why you didn't use them the
good hand that could do a lot much more
effectively there that reminds me of one
of those hotel ding ding ding ding ding
doesn't in the lobby you know what I
judge your essential struggle to be
what's that I think it has something to
do with your dad if he were here right
now in this room with us what would you
say oh I don't know I'm not just a
busted no surprise for you John still
he's right here
here's your dad
[Applause]
and out here and and now just totally
let go go life is unpredictable when it
comes to mental health don't be a hero
you got it call the Institute and there
you go right there
one more final word sometimes the
greatest dad are you talking dad you
know I've asked you can I ever have want
you to know that oh okay sorry I know
where I was
sometimes the greatest superpower is
being a great listener
I found that man
you